to me it's Psychopathic totalitarian
control because if you look at the way
that the Chinese government has been
operating and who have they been working
with especially when it comes to a lot
of the bigger Elites it's always been
about beta testing the latest
surveillance technology whether it's the
social credit score whether it's
punishing people for thinking the wrong
thing whether it's finding people and
taking money out of their bank account
for jaywalking the latest and worst 1984
Vision you can imagine is being tested
right now in China and I think this goes
along with these lockdowns which are
which are continuing this larger
progression that they've been making
against free Humanity I I definitely
think you know we agree it's
dictatorship it's insane I guess my
question is the motivation behind it is
it just to experiment total control or
is there something motivating them
behind it like like uh carbon get carbon
emissions down there's too many people
in this country they want to reduce
population China doesn't give a damn
about carbon China is releasing all the
carbon in the world possibly